[موسيقى]
مساء الخير يجتمع اليوم وغدا اي 11 و12
يوليو الجاري 2023 كل اعضاء حلف الشمال
الاطلسي النيتو 31 في فيلينس عاصمه
ليتوانيا لمناقشه قضايا متعدده لكن اهمها
على الاطلاق ماذا نفعل مع اوكرانيا
اوكرانيا تلحف الحصول على عضويه الحلف
الان لكن اعضاء الحلف ومنقسمون حول قبول
اوكرانيا في الحلف على الاقل الان وفي
المستقبل المنظور بعضهم وتحديدا دول
اوروبا الشرقيه مثل بولندا ودول البلطيق
الثلاث ليتوانيا
يؤيدون انضمام اوكرانيا في اسرع وقت ممكن
حتى قبل انتهاء الحرب
اذكركم من القسم المشترك بين هذه الدول
الاربعه وتقدر تضيف لها اوكرانيا القاسم
المشترك بينهم هو القرب الجغرافي الشديد
مع روسيا والشعور الدائم بالخطر الروسي
بالاضافه الى مرارات تاريخيه يعني عميقه
الجذور اتجاه الروس يكرهونهم بشده
هذه الدول تؤيد مع اوكرانيا ضروره
الانضمام الان ايمانا منها بان هذا
الانضمام هو افضل حل لردع الروس عن
الاستمرار في الحرب الحاليه فضلا عن فضلا
عن يعني شن مزيد من الحروب في المستقبل
ويدللون على مواقفهم هذه بان بوتين لم يمس
اي دوله خلال السنوات الطويله الماضيه
داخل النيتو لكنه لم يتردد في العدوان على
الدول من خارج الحلف
ويؤكدون ان قبول اوكرانيا في الحلف الان
هو تصحيح الاخطاء الماضي لو كان حلف شمال
الاطلسي قد تم اوكرانيا وكذلك جورجيا
حينما اقترح الرئيس الامريكي جورج بوش
الابن ذلك في قمه النيتو في بوخارست اللي
هي عاصمه رومانيا في ابريل 2008 لما تجرا
بوتر من وجهه نظرهم على غزو جورجيا واقت
طاع جزءا من اراضيها في اغسطس من نفس
العام 2008
وما ضم شبه جزيره القرم الاوكرى
الاوكرانيه من وجهه نظرهم في 2014 ولا فكر
في غزو اوكرانيا مجددا مجددا في فبراير
والعاشت هذه الدول ومعها باقي دول العالم
في سلام سلام قائم على ردع الروس من اي
مغامرات عسكريه ضد جيرانها
لكن باقي الدول الحلف خصوصا الدول
الموجوده في جنوب اوروبا وفي الغرب بصفه
عامه اي الدول البعيده جغرافيا عن روسيا
وبالتالي شعورها بخطر من غزو روسي محتمل
اقل هذه الدول ومنها الدول المؤثره في
الحلف مثل الولايات المتحده والمانيا
وفرنسا وبريطانيا يتحفظون بدرجات مختلفه
على انضمام اوكرانيا للحلف على الاقل الان
وهذه الدول لها منطقها اول يعني بتبني هذا
التحفظ او الرفض على على اعتبارين اساسيين
الاعتبار الاول ان اوكرانيا ببساطه لم
تستوفي شروط الانضمام لحلف شمال الاطلسي
حلف شمال الاطلسي له شروط معروفه
منها نظام حكم ديمقراطي في اي دوله ترغب
في الانضمام للحلف منها تبني لاقتصاد
السوق الحر منها التوافق العسكري مع دول
حلف شمال الاطلسي عسكريا بحيث لا تكون
دوله في حلف شمال الاطلسي لكن لديها
منظومات تسليح واسعه
روسيه الصنع ان تكون قواتها العسكريه تحت
سيطره مدنيه منتخبه هي التي تحدد تحركات
القوات المسلحه وليس جنرالات الجيش كما
يحلو لهم وطبعا ان تكون هناك اليات واضحه
للسيطره على الفساد لماذا الحديث عن
الفساد لان اوكرانيا متهمة منذ سنوات
طويله من جانب الغرب باستشراء الفساد هناك
هذا اولا ثانيا اوكرانيا في حاله حرب الان
وفي الغالب سوف تكون جبهه ساخنه لسنوات
ضمير طويله انضمامها الان يضع الحلف في
احد خيارين سيئين الاول ان تفعل دول حلف
شمال الاطلسي الماده الخامسه من ميثاق
النيتو والخاصه بالدفاع المشترك والتي تنص
على ان الاعتداء على احد دول الحلف يتطلب
ان تهب باقي الدول لنجدتها ويترتب على ذلك
اعلان هذه الدول الحرب على روسيا اي حرب
عالميه ثالثه والثاني ان تنضم اوكرانيا
للحلف لكن تعجز هذه الدول عن تفعيل الماده
الخامسه من الميثاق تجنبا للسيناريو الحرب
العالميه الكارثي فتضعف الثقه في الحلف
ويفقد جدول انضمام اليه وهذا ما قاله عدد
من المسؤولين الغربيين ومنهم مسؤول الماني
تحدث لصحيفه تيليجراف وقال نصا برلين لا
تريد ان ترى فلاديمير بوتين يختبروا جديه
الماده الخامسه ما هو لو انضمت اوكرانيا
للحلف وواصل بوتين حربه على اوكرانيا
وعجزت هذه الدول خوفا من اندلاع حرب
عالميه ثالثه عن تفعيل الماده الخامسه سوف
اشجع ذلك من وجهه نظرهم بوتين على العدوان
على دول اخرى تنتمي لحلف شمال الاطلسي
الحلف بكامله سوف ينهار في ظل هذا
الانقسام بدا البعض يقدم تصورات اخرى منها
منح اوكرانيا الان ما يسمى
وما هي المنبر شيب اكشن بلان اللي هي خطه
عمل للانضمام مستقبلا لعضويه حلف شمال
الاطلسي طب وما الجديد في ذلك ليس هناك في
ذلك جديد اي دوله راغبه في الانضمام لحلف
شمال الاطلسي اذا كان هناك قبول من الحلف
لضمها بتخضع لي هذا البرنامج او هذه
المرحله
لانها عباره عن مرحله تمهيديه بتوفق فيها
اي دوله
اوضاعها لشروط الحلف اللي اشرت اليها منذ
قليل
وعندما توفق اوضاعها لا يوجد فتره زمنيه
محدده لهذه الخطه او لهذا البرنامج في اي
وقت قد يستغرق الامر عشره
اكثر من السنوات حتى توفق هذه الدوله
اوضاعها ثم تعرض يعرض الامر على دول حلف
شمال الاطلسي ولابد ان توافق الدول كامله
الواحد وتلاتين عضو او اكثر اذا زاد عدد
اعضاء حلف شمال الاطلسي لكن المقترح بيقول
ايه نمنحها الان رغم ان هي لا تستوفي
الشروط ورغم ان هي بازلت في حاله حرب
ونحاول ان نقلص بعض الاجراءات كنوع من
الاستثناء لاوكرانيا
بحيث ان احنا نسرع امد انضمامها للحلف
يعني مستقبلا هذا ليس جديدا ومحل جدال
يعني خصوصا ان في دول رافضه تماما يعني
يعني حتى لو المنبر شيب اكشن بلان ديت
بدات ففي دول في نهايه المطاف سوف تمارس
حق الفيتو على انضمامها انما الجديد
بيقولوا نبدا بذلك على امل انه اوكرانيا
تنضم في المستقبل
كنوع من اظهار الجديه في رغبتنا في ضمها
لكن على ان يترافق مع منح اوكرانيا طريقا
للانضمام لحلف شمال الاطلسي
على ان يترافق مع ذلك
اعطاء ضمانات امنيه لاوكرانيا وهذه
الضمانات الامنيه سوف تمنح بشكل فردي من
جانب اعضاء حلف شمال الاطلسي وليس من جانب
حلف شمال الاطلسي يعني الولايات المتحده
باعتبارها الولايات المتحده سوف تمنح
الضمانات الامنيه المانيا بريطانيا فرنسا
كل الدول الراغبه في مساعده اوكرانيا
عسكريا وطبعا اقتصاديا سوف تفعل ذلك وسوف
توقع اتفاقات مع اوكرانيا كتعويض لها عن
عدم قدره هذه الدول على ضمها لحلف شمال
الاطلسي الان
هذا الخيار سماه البعض بخيار اسرائيل او
ازريل اوبشن
البعض مثل من مثل بيض نفسه هذا الخيار
يعني ببساطه الا تنضم اوكرانيا للحلف ولكن
يسعى اعضاء الحلف وعلى راسهم الولايات
المتحده
بتدعيم قدرات اوكرانيا العسكريه بحيث تصبح
قادره ذاتيا على الدفاع عن نفسها تماما
كما فعلت الولايات المتحده مع اسرائيل
وهذا الخيار يسمى احيانا بخيار بوركوباين
او بوركوباين اوبشن ما هو البورتو باين
اللي هو حيوان النيص انا لا اعرف حيوان
النيس ولكن عرفت ان هو بيشبه حيوان القنفذ
الذي اعرفه وسواء كان النايس القنفذ
البروكوباين المعنى واضح جدا ان دوله
صغيره
بتزود باسلحه فعاله لردع خصم اكبر كما
يفعل القنفذ او النيص
باشواكه المؤ في مواجهه خصم كبير اعمل كده
او النايس في مواجهه الحيوانات المفترسه
تقدر تفهم المثل بشكل واضح المتحمسون
لخيار النايس او القنفذ او ما يسمى بخيار
اسرائيل يعتقدون ان هذا النموذج اثبت
فاعليته في حاله اسرائيل التي لا تربطها
اتفاقات دفاعات مشتركه رسميه مع الولايات
المتحده تفرض على امريكا ان تهب لنجده
اسرائيل اذا تعرضت الى عدوان
ولكن بدلا من الاتفاقات الرسميه
الولايات المتحده امدت اسرائيل على مدار
السنوات بالاسلحه والتكنولوجيا اللازمه
لحمايه نفسها وردع اي دوله من الاعتداء
المحتمل على اسرائيل
هذا الخيار له مشاكله كما ان خيار انضمام
اوكرانيا الان او في المستقبل المنظور
لحلف شمال الاطلسي له مشاكله وصعوباته
خيار الباركوباين او خيار اسرائيل له
مشاكله لكن قبل الحديث عن مشاكله افتح
قوسين كبيرين جدا لملحوظه لا يجب ابدا ان
نغفلها تشبيه اسرائيل باوكرانيا في هذا
السياق خاطئ مضلل مبني على جهل استسهال في
التشبيهات
ابسط اوجه الاختلاف بين اوكرانيا واسرائيل
في هذا السياق
اختلاف يعني ينفي المقارنه من الاساس
ويجعل من تعبير الخيار الاسرائيلي تعبير
لا معنى له هو ان اسرائيل هي التي لم تكن
متحمسه لاتفاق دفاع مشترك مع الولايات
المتحده حتى لا تربط نفسها باولويات
الولايات المتحده ما هو الدفاع اتفاق دفاع
مشترك مع امريكا يعني في نهايه المطاف ان
امريكا هي التي سوف تحمي اسرائيل وليس
العكس ممكن اسرائيل تتعاود معها انما
الاساس فيه ان الولايات المتحده الدوله
العظمى هي التي سوف تحمي اسرائيل الصغيره
اذا كان الامر على هذا النحو في اسرائيل
مضطره وفقا لهذا الاتفاق الذي قد يورط
الولايات المتحده في حروب ان تستشير
وتستاذن الولايات المتحده في كل تحركاتها
مع دول الجوار واسرائيل لا تريد ذلك ثقه
منها فانها قادره ان تفعل ما تشاء
بقدراتها الذاتيه التي لمتها الولايات
المتحده على مدار 70 سنه
وشاركت دول غربيه اخرى في تغذيه القدرات
الاسرائيليه العسكريه ثم ان علاقه امريكا
باسرائيل علاقه استثنائيه في العلاقات
الدوليه هي علاقه ام بابنتها لا تحتاجوا
اصلا لاتفاقاتك ومع ذلك هناك قانون اقره
الكونجرس بعد حرب 73
بيلزم الولايات المتحده بان تجعل اسرائيل
اكثر تفوقا عسكريا على كل اعدائها في
المنطقه وهذا القانون يلزم اي رئيس جمهوري
او ديمقراطي بالتفوق العسكري الاسرائيلي
على كل دول المنطقه على العموم اذا
تجاهلنا التضليل واخذنا اسم الخيار خيار
اسرائيلي يعني على علاته او تجاهلنا الاسم
كله واتكلمنا على خيار البوركو باين او
النايس او فهمنا كل هذه المسميات على
حقيقتها وهو انه عباره عن دعم عسكري غربي
يمكن اوكرانيا من الدفاع عن نفسها دون
تورط النيتو في حرب مع روسيا بشكل مباشر
فهو اولا ليس جديدا هذا ما يحدث منذ بدايه
الحرب بالفعل
اذا حبينا نقول رقم فنقول ان اوكرانيا
حصلت في اول 16 شهر يعني تقريبا حتى الان
على 160 مليار دولار مساعدات عسكريه
واقتصاديه من دول الناتو منهم
76.8 يعني حوالي 77 مليار دولار مساعدات
عسكريه واقتصاديه من الولايات المتحده
نفسها ده رقم ضخم جدا ال 160 من كل دول
حلف شمال الاطلسي
او ال78 اللي الولايات المتحده اعطتهم الى
اوكرانيا لكن هذا لا يرضي الاوكران لانها
لان هذه المساعدات في نهايه المطاف هي
مساعدات طبيعيه وغير ملزمه هي ترغب في ان
تكون هذه المساعدات ملزمه كما ان الماده
الخامسه في ميثاق حلف شمال الاطلسي ملزمه
ليه هي بتصر طبعا هي مدركه انه لو هنتكلم
عن الخيار الاسرائيلي ده الاوكراني
فالخيار الاسرائيلي مبني على فكره التزام
طويل الامد وهذا بدوره يعني ان هذا
الالتزام لا يرتبط بمن هو في السلطه في
واشنطن اللي هي الدوله الرئيسيه اللي
هتقدم المساعدات وفي كيف الدوله التي سوف
تتلقى المساعدات في حاله اسرائيل
المساعدات مستمره منذ يعني نشاتها في
اواخر الاربعينات بقطع النظر عن من هو في
السلطه في واشنطن جمهوري ديمقرا طي
وبقطع النظر عن من هو في السلطه في
اسرائيل اما في حاله كيف فصحيح ان هم الان
دعموها بشكل سخي جدا بيتكلم على حوالي 78
مليار دولار لكن هذا الدعم قد يتغير قد
يقل قد يخف قد يتوقف تماما اذا جاء مثلا
الرئيس الجمهوري
ترامب في العام المقبل انتخابات 2024 قد
يخف قد يتراجع قد يتوقف اذا جاء رئيس اخر
خلاف زيلينسكي فشل في حشد الدعم الامريكي
والدعم الغربي قد يتغير كل شيء اذا واذا
واذا واذا ليس هناك الزام
يضمن تدفق هذه المساعدات الغربيه
والامريكيه الى اوكرانيا وحتى لو افترضنا
ان هناك الزام في شكل اتفاقات دفاع مشتركه
فرديه بين اوكرانيا والولايات المتحده
ووافق عليها الكونجرس ووافقت عليها وافق
عليها الب البريطاني والبرلماني الفرنسي
والبرلماني الالماني الى اخره لو افترضنا
ذلك فهذا الخيار عمليا يعني تزويد
اوكرانيا باسلحه بالغه التطور تمنحها
تفوقا نوعيا على كل اعدائها الحقيقيين
والمحتملين في حاله اسرائيل التي واجهت
وتواجه دول عربيه اضعف لم يكن الامر صعبا
لم يكن صعبا ان تتمكن الولايات المتحده من
تحقيق التفوق العسكري الكاسح لاسرائيل على
دول عربيه لكن في حاله اوكرانيا هذا يعني
التزام غربي بضخ تكنولوجيا عسكريه حساسه
بالاضافه الى مليارات عشرات المليارات من
الدولارات سنويا حتى تمكن حتى تتمكن
اوكرانيا من امتلاك اسلحه اكثر تفوقا
او على الاقل تعادل الترسانه العسكريه
الروسيه اللي هي واحده من اقوى جيوش
العالم هل هذا معقول ان تتمكن دول الغرب
من خلق دوله تستطيع مجارات القوه العسكريه
الروسيه
اخيرا الخيار العسكري او اخيرا الخيار
المسمى بالخيار الاسرائيلي له حدود في
النهايه لو استمرت دول الغرب في تزويد
اوكرانيا باسلحه نوعيه تحقق لها تفوقا
وتلحق خسائر مؤلمه في الجيش الروسي هذا
سوف يدفع روسيا حتما للرد للرد على مصادر
التهديد وبالتالي سوف تكون دول حلف شمال
الاطلسي امام خيار المواجهه المباشره مع
روسيا التي حاولت الهرب منه بعدم ضم
اوكرانيا ليه الحلف الحقيقه المؤلمه التي
يدركها قاده حلف شمال الاطلسي جيدا ان
ورطتهم في اوكرانيا ومع اوكرانيا سوف تظل
قائمه حتى لو توقفت الحرب الان لماذا لان
هذه الحرب ايا كانت نتائجها لا يمكن ان
تؤدي الا لحروب اخرى تاليه هزيمه اوكرانيا
مثلا واستيلاء الروس على اراضي منها سوف
يخل رغبه في الانتقام من جانب اوكرانيا
وتصميم على استعاده اراضيها المسروقه بدعم
غربي واضح اي هزيمه بتؤدي الى صعود
التيارات القوميه الراغبه في الانتقام ما
يمهد الامر لاندلاع حروب مقبله هزيمه
روسيا اذا حدثت ستؤدي قطعا لنفس النتيجه
بل ان انتصارا ووصيا باهتا اي تمكن روسيا
من احتلال اراضي اوكرانيه بخسائر هائله
كما يحدث الان وبشكل يظهرها بشكل ضعيف
يعني ان روسيا سوف تسعى الى بناء قدراتها
العسكريه على طول الحدود مع اوكرانيا وكل
دول الف شمال الاطلسي وسوف نرى حرب
اوكرانيا وهكذا
ما يعني ان السؤال الحقيقي الذي يجب ان
يطرح من دول حلف شمال الاطلسي ليس ماذا
يجب ان نفعل مع اوكرانيا كما قلت في اول
الحلقه ولكن ماذا يجب ان نفعل مع روسيا
هذا السؤال مطروح على
دوائر صنع القرار في الغرب منذ 200 عام
وما زال مطروحا الان كما كان مطروحا على
مدار عشرات السنوات الماضيه ماذا يجب ان
يفعل الغرب مع روسيا
هذا سوف يكون موضوع حلقتنا المقبله ان شاء
الله اشكركم والى